what was the what was the meeting the me
is a you know and I don't think I could
come on that was not the important part
of the story I know but if there's a job
in it for me that is important it's an
important question for me to ask there
what is a job in it for you oh it's a
porn because I remember the valley I see
porn stars all the time god no but
there's a part for you it was stunning
how to [ __ ] I've had it like I don't
want I never like want to be happy
because you always wait for the other
shoe to drop and [ __ ] right but it's
been a wonderful week for me that
episode of the flash air that I directed
yeah you guys see that as Flash boy that
was good
well done sir I've never [ __ ] done
anything in my life that had more people
gone holy [ __ ] good good job like
22-year career man not even in the
beginning when they liked me in [ __ ]
never had anybody react like to
something like the episode of the flesh
so it's like doing that has opened up
weird doors and since I came back from
the flash they're like three projects
that I set up and the one that I was
going in on today was pretty [ __ ]
massive goes back to my like childhood
and [ __ ] like that
I don't think and it was just [ __ ]
say it I was meeting with em yes MGM yes
MGM they have it's [ __ ] when you walk
in there's like a Wizard of Oz - yes
they got a deep library man they're not
just the MGM movies movies they've
acquired over years and years of [ __ ]
and so does anybody and not everyone
knows this movie but does anyone know
the movie The Adventures of Buckaroo
Banzai across the 8th dimension the
world and largely responsible for the
weird [ __ ] that I make because that
movie was supposed to be one thing but
it did it in another way just did it
very off center right so I've loved it
for years it was a movie I had to hunt
down like when I first heard about read
about in Starlog there was no internet
or anything like that wanted to see this
movie then suddenly it was in a theater
and out of a theater so like I was the
first to get I kept going in a video
store and being like do you guys have
buckaroo banzai and I like never heard
of that and [ __ ] and then finally one
day the guy was like I saw it in the
catalog so we'll have it in like three
months
and they put up a putt this is back in
the day no can you imagine waiting three
months in a weird man like when they
back then a stream was something nice a
piece up in a fishing pole so you know I
remember they put up a poster I can I
get that [ __ ] poster important as I've
loved this movie forever because I was
did the episode of the flash and then
suddenly I was had a foot in television
I guess which was a signal like oh he'll
[ __ ] do TV or something like that
which is weird because I've been doing
TV for five seasons six seasons now we
got renewed for comic book men right but
that's that's different thank you very
tepid yeah I've seen that show whoa yeah
but nothing scripted suddenly like I do
I've kind of got pulled into the
scripted world Dovan headfirst as well
MGM said hey we hear that you like
buckaroo banzai they heard that because
of a [ __ ] podcast I did in New York
and Lincoln Center where we did an
episode of smoothie Ola with a Peter
Weller and John Lithgow and watched
buckaroo banzai and I talked about how
much I loved it and [ __ ] like that so
they called my agent know like we we
think we'd like to talk to him about you
know we did with Fargo took Fargo and
turned it into a TV show and it's won
awards I'm sure they were like we have
another property that we want to do that
with and we were wondering if he's
interested in he's ever heard of
buckaroo banzai
my agent called me up and he was like
you ever hear of a movie called buckaroo
banzai and I was like you wish by the
way
yeah but it was very what your mouth on
that table but it was very dramatic and
he was like you know this was like dude
this was my childhood this is why I'm
one of the reasons I make [ __ ] up
movies why can't be like JJ and [ __ ] hey
I'm not talented and B because I thought
getting buckaroo banzai was a [ __ ] that
appealed to me it's like they didn't do
it straightforward they did a very left
of senators a very funny movie very
weird yes
so because the weird movies like I've
been doing lately tusks [ __ ] yoga
hosers and because I drove into TV
suddenly people went two plus two equals
five let's have him come in so I went in
met with those cats and we talked about
like what would you do to turn it into a
series that's what we wanted to Wow
that's cool so I was like oh my lord
like well I've loved this movie forever
if you're gonna do that basically you
just do the entire movie for a season
one and then season two you finally do
the sequel we've all dreamed about
buckaroo banzai vs. the world crime
league and [ __ ] so when went back and
forth and before we knew it we were in
business together so we finished this
deal to develop buckaroo banzai and the
next month we take it out and try to
find a home for it but these cats are
very good at finding homes for things
and there's already some like oh [ __ ]
like people kind of heard early and have
asked so if all goes well I think we'll
be doing buckaroo banzai as a series
congratulations thank you
so we'll see knock wood but you know in
this town it's like you get this far
it's kind of [ __ ] cool it's all about
like we pushed it this forward push to
this far so the next thing is finding a
network home for it man but I'm excited
to [ __ ] it's fine it's crazy I'm gonna
reach out to the guy that created all of
the entire world if you don't know
anything about it's it's amazing [ __ ]
sci-fi movie kind of it's very sci-fi
but it's like superhero to their
economic book is its own franchise all
in one flick and it is meant to like go
on but it just kind of lived and died
with this movie that never found an
audience and the studio that released it
didn't know what to do with it really
so it's found its audience long since on
video and for years they've talked about
maybe a sequel maybe just sequel but
they're like the TV show is the way to
go so I would reach back to everybody
who was in the show and bring them in as
well not playing the same characters
probably but
laying the bad guys know how that'll
kind of do like peter weller if you know
the world of buckaroo banzai there's a
joker like character his lex luthor that
they didn't put in the movie but he's in
the comic books he's in the novelization
by Alma crock the guy who I've reached
out to millet come help me with this guy
named Hana why Shan is the guy who
killed his parents and [ __ ] right that's
right away I'd go to Peter Weller and be
like dude play Hana hua Shan because
he's the guy in in real life Peter
Weller is the guy that made buckaroo
banzai by his performance he is buckaroo
banzai so it'd be kind of cool that like
in our mythology he made buckaroo banzai
because he's the one that kills his
parents so we flipped the script Peter
can play a villain we've seen him do it
in the Star Trek movie instead and he's
a real [ __ ] sweet guy have that
podcast I did about buckaroo banzai did
another one out here with him about the
Dark Knight Returns when that came out
and he was so [ __ ] sweet when I
introduced him I was like Peter Weller
and he grabs the mic is let me tell you
a story about this guy in the hockey
jersey he's gonna know who the hell he
was a few months ago and he's gone well
once at Lincoln Center and we did this
thing and like you know this movie
nobody ever understood it I still don't
get it
they wanted me and Lithgow to introduce
it and both of us were baffled and so
all of a sudden this guy in hockey
jersey gets up and eloquently spits out
five minutes worth of material about
this movie I turned to lift guy was like
if this fat guy was here when the movie
was out we would have made failure so
it's sweet dude so I hope to pull him
into it as well if he doesn't want to do
if he's like that's what I used to do
because he's now a doctor like a PhD
doctor right you know maybe he doesn't
want to act or something or particularly
do something that he'd done before but
if we could find a way to weave them in
an original way that'd be badass but
anyway there is a [ __ ] role for you
my friend yeah and there's a role for me
for Jay Mewes like everybody I'll be
able to kind of put into roles I want me
and if you remember the movie the the
red lectroids the ones that like were
played by Christopher Lloyd played one
right I would that was John big booty
Chevelle II and yes yes key value I
would be I would play the the John big
booty roll and Muse would be the ski of
Ellie rule that
so already I'm like oh my god we could
do this put on the rubber makeup like
it's all the [ __ ] I've been doing lately
it's perfect training for this it's it's
kind of exciting to me so I don't know I
didn't get I didn't mean to share it
tonight sorry we should be laughing in a
comedy club but no that's good that's
great news back in actually dragged out
of me all right so I'm with the show
[ __ ] now right